[Musique]
on est en plein cœur de Poitier on est
dans le jardin de brotille pour les
fleurs comestibles et tout ce qui est
graines germé micropousce c'est en labo
plus connu on va dire ça va être la rose
ça va être la bourrache le
bégonia l'ail toutes ces fleurs là qu'on
a l'habitude de manger il y en a
certaines que j'ai amené au jardin qu'on
connaît un petit peu moins comme les
flocs ou comme les tulbalgia qui sont
aussi comm ESBLE voilà j'ai j'ai au
moins 60 70 variétés différentes de de
fleurs c'est des fleurs de saison
uniquement fleurs fraîches comestible de
saison et donc depuis on va dire mi-mars
ça va dépendre de la météo de mi-mars
jusqu'à mi-octobre je peux livrer des
fleurs comestibles on a des fleurs qui
sont plus qui vont être très acidulés
comme le bégonia on a des fleurs d'ail
bien sûr qu' ont un goût puissant d'ail
les fleurs de tajette qui vont avoir un
goût très agrume pamplemousse souvent
utilisé en décoration qu'on va rajouter
au dernier moment sur le plat que ce
soit un plat salé ou un plat de dessert
sucré ça peut être utilisé aussi plus en
va dire en salade
comme son des salades sucré de salad
salé on peut en mettre plusieurs soit en
pétal soit la fleur entière en fonction
de la la taille de la fleur et du rendu
qu'on veut obtenir maintenant les les
chefs viennent au jardin goûtent les
fleurs goûteent les feuilles et me
disent ah bah oui moi cette C cet été ou
cette saison je veux travailler avec ça
avec la feuille de bégonia ou avec la
feuille de Capucine ou avec la fleur de
tajette voilà ils sont très attentifs à
l'accord goût de la fleur et plat sur
lequel au mariage voilà ça ça ça rentre
dans la composition de leur plat voilà
graines germé et micropousce donc c'est
de c'est on va dire c'est un peu la même
chose c'est c'est travaillé un petit peu
différemment euh la graine germée et la
micropousce se travaill donc en labo à
l'intérieur euh et là on a pareil on a
une gamme de saveurs très différentes on
a des très doux jusqu'au très épicés
avec des gûts de radis ou de poireau
très piquants et des fleurs des des
graines geré ou des micropousces
beaucoup plus douce comme l'alpalpha ou
le trelf qui vont être là plus des
aliments très riches en en protéines
végétal donc très intéressant pour
ramener sur des plats végétariens ou des
assiettes végétariennes alors pour les
les professionnels pour les chefs je je
cueille le jour de la livraison et
j'amène j'apporte les fleurs en vrac
donc il y a pas d'emballage après le le
chef les conditionne lui dans ses dans
ses propres contenants euh pour le grand
public tout ce qui va être grain germé
c'est c'est en des dans des boîtes et je
les livre dans les magasins soit bio
soit les magasins de producteurs sur
tout Poitier voir un petit peu Châtel R
et
montmillon n'oubliez pas je suis à deux
PES chez
[Musique]
vous